ciao maria 6 benvenuti a nuovissimo
video o vi farò vedere gli acquisti che
ha fatto da l'ultimo video ad oggi c'è
stato cambio di stagione di mezzo quindi
non è fissa tema
ma andiamo ad analizzare bene il tutto
un capo per volta ma prima di vedere il
capo per capo i miei nuovi acquisti devo
assolutamente salutare 3d voi vi ricordo
che fini video troverete le istruzioni
per farvi salutare nel prossimo video
oggi saluto genio mondini linda de fiore
francesca appunto bottiglieri un bacione
ciao allora da dove iniziamo ragazzi e
ragazze iniziamo dai maglioncini perché
vi devo confessare una cosa ho comprato
maglioncini per avere la scorta fino
insomma quando avrò 50 anni e non mi
ricordo quanti siano ma vi faccio vedere
partiamo dal primo ed è subito autunno
lo intitolerei è una sorta di foglia di
maglioncino versione foglia un colore
molto autunnale ve lo farò vedere poi
addosso magari delle storie un po
abbondante però carino veste bene una
bella visibilità insomma una foglia che
cade dall'albero l'autunno poi questo
maglioncino sempre molto bucolico con
queste mani chi le vede subito
raperonzolo un po come direbbe mia madre
vittoriano
non è un po vittoriano e nero
rigorosamente leggerino
ma molto carino poi praticamente mai
successo che nella mia vita passata ero
cappuccetto rosso quindi appena ho visto
questa fantastica felpa con tanto di
cappuccio veramente veramente morbido
oddio i capelli elettrici
ecco mi sono innamorata quindi l'ho
comprata prossimamente
interpreterò cappuccetto rosso
preparatevi per il prossimo video e non
l'ho ancora messo cioè mi piaceva tanto
ma è ancora lui col cartellino
vedremo se la sfrutterò poi passerei a
un capitolo che si chiama 50 sfumature
di maglioncini rosa allora non volevo
farmi mancare nessuna delle sfumature
del rosa quindi ho preso questo
maglioncino
come lo definiamo questo rosa rosa
intellettuale ok un po cambridge e un po
oxford un po brava ragazza tra l'altro
l'ho già usato l'ho messo a pranzo con
clio
salutiamo clio era il nono feat poi
questo rosa bello bellissimo rosa c
classic ata ci piace un po stracciona ma
underground comunque a trovare molto
underground molto circa ma molto urban
passiamo a quest'altra la pro questa
città attenzione questa è color chica
questa è color circa appena scartata
insomma quindi prima del processo di
masticazione soprattutto cento dei
lavori vi sentite dai rumori strani
sappiate che è tutto normale ma passiamo
nata e sfumature di rosa questo come lo
chiamiamo questa rosa
questo lo definirei rosa disney perosa
disney questo è ora si sveglia al
mattino e si addormenta subito dopo
quindi questo per la bella addormentata
a questo non lo possiamo definire rosa è
più vero e più news
niente è una semplicissima femmina krogh
top con il cappuccio con questo
dettaglio molto carino di strass
dovete come si dice tene avere un
cassetto a parte perché se mai dovesse
incontrare il filamento di qualche altro
maglioncino ecco avete buttato dei soldi
e maglioncini perché vi rovina tutti
quindi questa praticamente io non l'ho
messa dei casi gli angoli perché ho
paura della sua aggressività sempre di
rosa avevo anche un altra roba questa
qui cos'è questo qui è rosa struzzo
struzzo asper occhiato questo è un dato
davvero che nata 7 poi chiedere tema
marina che problemi stare ovviamente
niente mi piaceva mi ricorda molto gli
anni 90
mi ricorda molto le spice girl
soprattutto emma bunton baby spice sachs
è molto carino questa anche
sapevate che dove l'hai presa dove l'hai
presa è un semplice zara tra l'altro
pagata pochissimo molto più vincente
nato un figlio vuole morire molto cure e
molto sobria già molto sobria come
possiamo definire un aggettivo oltre a
molto sobria pacchiana ma chiedo che ci
piace perché sono abbiniamo bene il
pacchiano bocchietto insisti reinbach
indie esatto il pacchiano con pacchetti
nella figura benissimo questa ci piaceva
poi c'è questa che è molto molto bella
anche questa per prezzo perché non avrà
avuto occasione di metterla me la
immaginavo in uno chalet di montagna
di fianco al camino in uno shooting da
chiara ferragni però non c'è né tamino
nello chalet di montagna quindi lo
metterò per fa una passeggiata ma però
poi ci mancare niente anche se autunno
stiamo andando verso l'inverno
mi piaceva questo cappellina non l'ho
ancora lo sta ridendo non lo avrò ancora
provato vista male è molto carino e
molto cure molto si muove sono così come
le orecchie del filtro di vista ma
quando parlo canto che si muovono così
io mi sono ancora vista casa temi dove
devono allora ragazzi e ragazze siamo in
diretta dei video praticamente era
rivolta e provo questo cappello che ho
comprato quindi volevo rendervi
partecipi e nel mentre stiamo
registrando quindi sarete nel prossimo
video youtube anche noi e passiamo al
mondo rimaniamo al mondo di sé ma
passiamo a crudelia de mon
questo e molto crudelia anche questa è
ancora presto perché forse sono in via
di cambiamento lasciato ancora capire se
vi piacciono
cosa ne pensi tu le foto sono top
proseguiamo mi sa che abbiamo finito con
i maglioncini grazie a dio perché come
vi dicevo fatto la scorta
passiamo allora come sapete è un punto
molto dolente
bene del male perché ho una passione
spiega tanta per le scarpe queste le
occupate ieri hanno questa soluzione
sorpreso le amo e mi piace un sacco sono
divenuti in ordine e mi piace molto il
contrasto tacco e scarpa e sono
comodissime quindi è la scarpa che
voglio usare tutti i giorni quando
voglio essere semigirata carina un po
più alta è però senza uccidermi il piede
queste sono da abbinare al quanto lungo
sono già usate quindi ecco aprire la
parentesi in una storia avevo detto che
questo modello così altissimo mi piace
un sacco mi piaceva un sacco danni solo
che sia mia mamma che salgono sempre
bocciato della serie ma dove vai
sembra il gatto dagli stivali con quella
roba addosso sei troppo bassa permette a
territorio tra la festa e voi
confermerete che quando la genitrice
toglietevi dalla testa di puntate ancora
il view quindi grazie anche sempre voi
sempre voci tra i colpevoli ma no fidati
anche io sono basse e un palo compra che
poi mi starò benissimo cosa faccio male
negozio nel libro opera prima volta
perché non devo niente mai provati me li
provo e mi sono innamorata bellissimi mi
stanno bene è una cazzata questa che 66
basta non ti stanno e stivali alti anche
per noi che lasciamo tutte e naomi
campbell quindi allora abbiamo fatto
vedere il tacco di tutti i giorni basso
il tacco quasi da tutti i giorni perché
ho bisogno e quindi un po più scomodo ma
comunque mettibile bello con lo stivale
bello alto ma quello che cercavo di ho
già detto nelle ore che stavo cercando
era lo stivaletto alla caviglia con un
bel tacco per la sera
e allora sono alti però non si sente
all'altezza perché come sempre nelle mie
scarpe c'è un po di platone sono un
ballo di modo appunto quindi brattle
hanno eliminato però senza prodotta un
male cane è invece queste mi fanno molto
alta e sono anche abbastanza comode mi
piace modello sono anche queste cose
cascino fano show passiamo alle scarpe
un po più comode quindi snake a sopresa
qualche sede lainate troppo top sempre
nero c'è sempre qua c'è un cielo roma
c'è un bel fluo e molto seria e molto
comode molto leggera e quindi anche per
andare in viaggio un bari già gravissime
poi ho preso questa borsa
diverse love e carne bellissima per
avere in palestra praticamente quale
esce dalla sip e mettete a non farcela
traforo non facciamo l'altra tra forma
non lo so comunque non scherziamo questa
è la testa davanti ovviamente trescato
la ginnastica
così non si inquina l'ambiente scarpe da
una parte il resto nell'altra ed è super
tocco e poi sempre in seno alle carni
questa fantastica giacchetta che però
per siremar in estate che al liceo
investì non solo di questi colori non
c'era loro nero e è stata un adolescenza
molte volte flusso è finita no c'è da
capire in bellezza la parte accessoria
allora la società prima di tutto si può
trasformare anche imparato travi dei
miei orecchini marina gli orecchini
marina ashkal orecchini hashtag sobrietà
e partiamo comunichino mortoni 90 cioè
se avessero girare una fiction i 90
questo sarebbe l'orecchino che
metterebbero belle attrici e anche
questo ho preso un mese fa ha messo
molto a questi insieme sia già messi
belli che si piacciono molto questi che
sempre molto tocco sobri ci sono
raffrescata di diamanti molto belli e
entriamo un po più nel mood ghetto
vi ricordate cosa ho detto ecco c'è
anche chi il primo è una sorta di come
la possiamo chiamare una maniglia fa
bello
così e questi con scritto baby ed è
subito justin bieber è subito molto
schietto li volevo coscritti adoro ma
purtroppo verso novità che ti adoro
oppure 18 o per altra d'oro quelli erano
proprio i miei mi sono accontentato
diciamo per ora infatti non ho mai messi
però non si sa mai che debba girare un
video insomma device anni 2000 con
questo è tutto ragazzi vi ricordo
brevemente gli step che dovete fare per
farvi salutare il prossimo video
seguirmi su instagram dv andare il tuo
sito ciao sono sarà salute nel prossimo
video e guardare il prossimo video su
youtube per vedere se siete tra i tre
fortunati che saluterò nel prossimo
video se il mito vissuto come al solito
iscriviti al canale e mettetevi un bel
like e lasciate un commento
se volete un nuovo video magari un po
natalizio mood che ci sta fatemelo
sapere
e adoro